لقد تضاعف الطلب على الإجهاض الدوائي أكثر
من الضعف منذ قرار المحكمة العليا يوم الجمعة
بإلغاء رو
في وايد ، وهي
منظمة تقدم
الإجهاض الدوائي في بعض الولايات من خلال
مواعيد افتراضية ، رئيس المراسلين الطبيين في
CNN الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا الذي
ينضم إلينا الآن في هذا اليوم.  بدأت تسمع
عن هذه الزيادة بعد هذا الحكم أه
هل يمكنك أن تخبرنا قليلاً عن
مدى
شيوع استخدام حبوب
الإجهاض للإجهاض ،
نعم بالتأكيد أعني أن هذا هو
الشكل الأكثر شيوعًا للإجهاض الآن وهو الشكل الأكثر
شيوعًا  من إجراء الإجهاض من
خلال هذه الأدوية الآن ، وإذا
ألقيت نظرة تاريخية على
ما تعرفه ، فإن ما يقرب من 30 عامًا بعد roe v
wade 27 عامًا في عام 2000 هي
عندما ظهرت بالفعل في السوق في
الولايات المتحدة ، هناك نسخة من
حبوب الإجهاض الدوائية هذه ويمكنك أن
ترى ما حدث على مدار العشرين
عامًا الماضية ، والآن يتم إجراء أكثر من نصف
عمليات الإجهاض هذه باستخدام هذه
الأدوية.  طبعات لإعطائك مزيدًا من السياق في عام
2019 وفقًا لمجلات منع الحمل ،
تم إجراء حوالي 629000 عملية إجهاض في الولايات المتحدة
، تم
إجراء حوالي 340.000 منها باستخدام هذه الأنواع من
الأدوية ، وعادةً
ما يتحدثون عن
دواءين عن ميفوبريستون وميزوبروستول.
الدواء الأول هو شيء
يمنع هرمون البروجسترون
بحيث
تبدأ البطانة الداخلية للرحم في الانهيار
وينهي الحمل بشكل فعال ، وبعد ذلك
بيومين عادة ما
تأخذ حبة ثانية ، لذلك كلاهما عن طريق
الفم حبة ثانية و  هذا النوع من
الأسباب يتسبب في تقلص الرحم نوعًا ما
لإزالة محتويات الرحم ،
وهذه هي الطريقة التي يعمل بها هذا الدواء
وأنت تعلم مرة أخرى أن الأرقام قد
ارتفعت ، ويمكنك أيضًا استخدامه
حتى حوالي 10 أسابيع أو نحو ذلك من
الحمل بعد 70 يومًا من آخر
سلامة فترة الحيض وفعاليتها
سانجي ، ما هي البيانات التي تُظهر
أسئلة كبيرة هنا ولكن كما قد
تتوقع نظرًا لأن هذه روبوتات
حبوب منع الحمل الفموية ، سجل الأمان كان جيدًا جدًا ،
يمكننا أن نظهر لك مرة أخرى هذه
وفقًا لهذه المجلات التي تدرس
هذا وتجد أن الأمان
من حيث المضاعفات الرئيسية حول النقطة أربعة
بالمائة هناك معدل وفيات
هو صفر صفر صفر واحد
في المائة ، لذا فهي فعالية آمنة حقًا
مرة أخرى في الأسابيع التسعة الأولى
أو نحو ذلك من الحمل ،
وستكون فعالة جدًا من حيث إنهاء
الإجهاض
99.6
خلال تلك الأسابيع التسعة الأولى ثم
الأسابيع من 10 إلى 11 تنخفض إلى 87 ولكنها
لا تزال
جميلة  ساري المفعول
حتى هذه النقطة ، فمن الذي سيظل لديه حق الوصول
إلى هذا
البئر ، هذا هو نوع السؤال المفتوح
الآن ، أعني أنك تعلم أننا كنا
نحاول البحث في هذا الأمر على مستوى الولاية حسب
مستوى الولاية ، فأنت تعلم أن هذا يختلف
بشكل واضح إذا كنت "  إعادة إرسال الحبوب
بالبريد
أثناء الجائحة في أبريل 2021 ،
أصبح هذا شيئًا يمكن
إرساله بالبريد ولا يتطلب بالضرورة
زيارة شخصية في وقت مبكر للحصول على
هذه  أنواع الأدوية سنرى ما إذا كان
هذا النوع من السياسة أه لا يزال
مؤيدًا وإذا كانت هذه الحبوب يمكن أن تتخطى حدود الحالة
أم لا ، لا أعرف ، لا أعرف كيف
سيحدث ذلك نوعًا ما ،
أعتقد أنه سيكون كذلك  من
المحتمل أن تكون صيدلية مختلفة عن صيدلية
وتذكر أن الأمور قائمة الآن
وأيضًا دور الرعاية الصحية عن بُعد في هذا
أيضًا الآن يمكنك القيام بزيارات الرعاية الصحية عن بُعد
التي يتعين عليك القيام بها
قبل الزيارة وبعدها ولكن يمكنك
القيام بذلك من خلال  منزل خاص